okay
you can carry on now thank you very much
so um
as i say we've uh well welcome back to
people
watching on youtube firstly we're going
to go
to a vote now on the uh proposition from
council laws councilman goff
visa v1610
and that is to go to the end of the
contract with the what was the amendment
went with it sorry
um uh
steve what was that and bit that was
went with it
i wrote it down here i can't read my own
writing now
okay he didn't write it down i don't
know if somebody else has
well done it was to keep torridge um
storage pool open yes very decision on
the
holes where the entire infant calls
defer a decision on uh oh to
defer on um pose-worthy is that right
and torrington
is that right stacy that that's correct
and to allow the cheating
the what sorry head office j the
costs going forward sorry chad did you
hear me so it was
it was to continue to the end of the
contract
allow the chief executive the section
151 officer and head of
legal to negotiate the costs going
forward with the options to
keep torrington and holdsworthy
discussions going forward right
good everybody understand that so
we'll go to the vote now
sorry chair council about him uh
four councillor brenton
or answer bright
against council brown
for councillor bushby
against councillor christie
or council clerk
against
councillor cottle hankin four
councillor dart
four
council harding or
councillor hawkins thanks
councillor against
councillors
council hex
oh
against councillor james
paul councillor jones
against us i want to see holes in the
open sooner
a language for
councillor laws
cancel the laws
golf four
council mackenzie against
[Music]
councillor manly for
councillor newton against
councillor pennington
councillor watson
right thank you very much mary well
that's uh
that's carried and shows by the vote the
depth of feeling there is in this issue
so councillors um thank you very much
for your contributions tonight that's
been another long meeting i'm afraid
but there we are before
cheer before you end before you end the
meeting we've got to consider
the request from 1610 which is shown on
your screen
now um in respect of the payments
because that's something that
they'll need a response on so obviously
you agreed at the last meeting to pay
uh the 116 000 over the months november
to march
um they have obviously indicated they
want that
um as indicated by the bullet points on
the screen so
members need to consider i'm not
i've got the right thing on mine i don't
think what is it
seven yeah
sorry yeah so it's item seven the top uh
bullet point and the sub bullet points
so obviously you'd agree to pay 116
000 equally over five months uh they've
since come back and requested that to be
paid
um the march to august costs up front
67 000 september and october um
next month although the figures have
changed from
49 000 to 68 000
which we are continuing to discuss with
them and then november
onwards the month following the invoice
so it's the
the first two bulleted parts some
bulletin points
in terms of the payment members need to
consider
well do we have an officer
recommendation on this
in terms of going forward with
negotiations etc etc
it would be good if we had some an
officer recommendation
well he was done originally chair in
terms of ongoing
discussions obviously you've indicated
you want discussions going
to continue
they've worded their letter very
strongly in terms of uh wanting the
money
paid up front as i'd uh detailed
um in the part two area of the of the
report
which is a member to consider really
whether you want
and prepared to pay that money up front
or not
right so it's very simple pay it up
front or not
chair you have another number of hands
raised yes
yes should you go into part two
i have my hand up first how do you know
actually i had my hand up first
counselor pushed me on the screen
counselor i think i was up first
councillor hutchins was the first hands
raised
yes thank you councillor bushby
dear oh dear oh dear right if we're
gonna have a discussion about this one
then we will have to go back into part
two now won't we
uh through the chair i'd like to make
i'd like to make a proposal
um that we stick to what we vote on at
the last meeting
however should all three pools open up
we will pay them in full at that point
right that's a proposal secondary for
that yes
seconded by councillor watson right
i'm minded to take a vote on that take
it then
i will so we've got a proposal from
councillor
um hutchins well you heard his proposal
that we stick to what we agreed before
uh
subject to what was it sorry cancer
hatchets fill me in again
subject to all through three polls being
open in which case we'll pay them the
remainder in full
right it's very clear concise you can
all understand that one
so i'm going to go to a vote on this one
council about him for
council brenton or council bright
council brown for councillor bushby
against
councillor christie or
councillor clark or
councillor cottle hunkin or
councillor dart four
councillor ford four
councillor grub
hawkins gangs
councillor happle yeah
council higgs
four four
thank you council hudson
council holly or
councillor hutchings
four councillor james
or councillor jones
or councillor langford
or councillor laws
four council mackenzie
paul councillor manly
councillor manley councillor manny left
the meeting
thank you councillor newton
paul
councillor pennington
thank you jeff that is 31 4 and
1 sorry 30 34 and two against
right thank you very much mary well it
says on my screen
counselors low battery i don't know that
refers to the technology
or me but i safely say it does refer to
me
uh okay so um we must conclude the
meeting now and um
thank you very much for your input quite
a long one tonight so
uh look forward to seeing you all again
in two weeks time oh please stay safe
through the check can i just ask it
those slides are sent to the councillors
please especially that one that was in
part one please with the figures on
okay yeah there's no reason why you
shouldn't get that okay
so as i say keep safe please